[Music]
hello, how are you, sal y jaramillo greets you
with their informative brief for today, tuesday
, june 22, the first
foreign property in las vegas after a decade is
preparing to open this thursday
night the 4.3 billion dollar research world
it was planned since may
bryant and perry are some of the
artists who will present their shows at
this property visit news now punto con
diagonal in spanish to find out
other details about the grand opening and
if you still want to vaccinate we will tell you
that the casting man  Organize a clinic
this Friday where you can get
free tickets for a game of the
light beams & if you heard correctly if you
register in advance through the
health district page and show up to
vaccinate you will get two tickets for a
game of the health team  las vegas soccer
the event will be from four thirty to
eight thirty for more information visit
our page viva the heights if you are
looking for work fashi  on show mount is
hiring for over 300
jobs there will be a job fair
today from 3 to 7 pm you don't need to
make appointments just show up and fill out your
application and now we move on to
the weather forecast we will have temperatures
reaching 104 degrees today with
some clouds in the valley however
the temperatures will continue to rise as we
approach the weekend
exceeding 108 degrees
remember to drink a lot of water and not be
exposed to the sun for several hours
have a nice day I am salt and jaramillo
and this was your brief informative  from news
now in Spanish
[Music]